[Music]
in culinary school they did a section of
pastry
and it was the first time where like the
butter and the sugar
it just felt like home whereas
everything else i was doing in school it
was like not as natural or easy
so in the end i guess
it found me i didn't really have a
choice
[Music]
my name is chef madison lee and i am a
chef and cake artist owner of madison
lease cakes
my dad owns a bakery and then my mom was
always baking in the house i just i grew
up with it piping bag in hand was always
completely natural
what i do here is so different from like
what my dad does it's probably more what
my mom always dreamed of doing
i don't think anyone really
knows
how much work it actually is to get the
kicks out on time and really make them
the process starts
anywhere from
a year to
six months in advance the couple's taste
i build in styrofoam so that they can
physically see it i've learned their
whole story how they met how they got
engaged i get on my ipad and i start
sketching sometimes it's easy where
they're looking for something that
matches the florals and things like that
and then there's other times where
they really don't know that i have to
dig deeper and figure out like
what their aesthetic is
it's not just even about them it's just
about me it's actually about us together
and creating something that represents
them
so i would tell them to like leave their
pinterest things at home
and just
like enjoy it like you got enough stress
with planning a wedding like have the
cake be cake cake is meant to put a
smile on your face and enjoy
[Music]
i wanted to learn
from people who i admired
one thing i really learned in culinary
schools it's really not about the school
it's really about the person that
mentors you and gives you their love for
whatever the trade is
so i went to hyde park this woman betty
van ostern she like started sugar
flowers and things like that here in the
united states she taught sylvia
weinstock she taught roman israel and
as i was coming up those were my huge
idols and i thought okay i don't want to
learn from them i want to learn who
taught them like that seemed like
the better way to go the more research i
did about cakes and things i learned
that it really wasn't something from
here it's actually from the uk
there was nothing like that here that i
could find
so i went to the bank i emptied my bank
account
i packed a backpack i went to jfk
i bought a ticket to london
no phone no computer no nothing
and
i was there for four months i learned
from
as many people as i could people i loved
who i so admired
i learned
a history and like a respect for it
we're here
it was like oh that's on tv it doesn't
matter there it was like an honor to be
making cakes it was something of like
real value
[Music]
so when i came back not only had my
whole
view of like cakes and what they
represented and how
it was a tradition i was like fulfilling
everything really changed and clicked i
think that's where madison lee's cakes
really came from
that whole experience of almost breaking
away but bringing all these different
things kind of back
i want the cake to taste as moist and as
fresh as possible
i think the taste is the most important
part of the cake i mix the batter by
hand i think it makes a difference i i
feel like my heart goes into the design
and then it's like my soul that goes
into the batter
it's it's a part of me just as much as
it's a part of them
you get to the wedding and you're
overwhelmed how beautiful the tables are
and the centerpieces and the ambiance
and the lighting and you're totally
blown away and then all the way in the
corner of the room
you're looking at what's not
you're not looking at a wedding cake
anymore you're looking at
a piece of art that fits the room
and but when you walk next to it it
smells sweet and delicious so your eyes
fix on it
you smell it so now all of a sudden it
starts like oh my gosh i get to eat it
and you get to look at it for almost the
whole night at least four
hours the wedding cake is also the last
thing you typically eat
it's your last memory of the whole
experience you had
right from when you got that first
invitation to even go to this wedding
and if you take a bite of that cake and
it's not the best piece of cake you've
ever eaten
you don't remember
anything else besides that it wasn't a
good piece of cake
the taste in the inside is
critical
it's critical to the whole thing
the inside is the most important
it has to taste good
it has to
[Music]
so the week of the wedding on wednesday
we start we start baking
so
i can't i can't really start that much
in advance because you'll have old style
cake
we bake we cut phil on wednesday every
single bride couple whomever
is always disappointed in something i've
never heard of anybody having like a
completely perfect picture wedding of
everything they wanted something always
goes wrong my biggest fear is they're
gonna
turn around and say like oh it was the
cake that was wrong and thank god
in 10 years nobody's ever said that
but
you never know i'm learning to be
confident with it
that i should
be more forthcoming that
i'm 31 and that i've had the company for
so long and that
that i've done so much i mean i'm i want
to keep evolving and growing so
to be the best is to almost be stagnant
[Music]
friday's the toughest day
friday
we cover dowel stack
i would say the covering's the hardest
because it's freezing in here
the cakes are big
and i'm only five feet
and even though my clogs add an extra
two inches which like really does help i
have to be smarter about it like
standing on the buckets or like i lean
on the table more it's hot they're big
they're really big and i love that
they're big i think it's great
and we try to finish the cake on friday
try i say try because
each one's different so like you don't
really know
[Music]
you always want the cake to sleep
overnight that's like ideal
but sometimes overnight never like ends
sometimes it just like keeps going
if it means that
i'm here where like my whole team is
here
around the clock we're here
you really you can't mess up
there is no there is no second chance
you have to work smarter not harder
honestly if you can cut it in my kitchen
for a year
you can you'll be fine
i'm super meticulous if that's how i was
brought up in such tough strict kitchens
that's how i'm that's that's what i'm
gonna know here like you're a product of
how you how you grew up really it's not
going anywhere i can't i can't make that
go away
there could be more there's you could
always be better you could always be
pushing it's new york city if you stop
someone else coming
they're coming for you
you have to show up and it has to be
perfect
i'm easily here at least 16 18 hours a
day easily
if not more
i love it
so where else would i be at home
watching tv for what
you should feel more you should feel it
you should put your heart into it
because
you're creating something for someone's
wedding day it's a day that they'll
never forget
and it's an honor to be a part of the
celebration that's probably the biggest
virtue i would say
[Music]
as you're in it
you don't realize that each step is like
one step closer to this thing
that comes together like so fast
it comes together just as fast as like
they cut it and knead it
it's done when i say it's done i don't
care what was on the sketch i don't care
what was talked about in an email or on
a phone call
it's done
when i think it looks like a completed
work
and then it's
it's a piece of art at the wedding like
i know the inside's great but it has to
look appropriate and right and that's my
art
yeah everything on my cake you can eat
everything's 100 edible
everything's made by hand
one petal at a time
painted individually
it feels so fast that i drew it on a
piece of paper and then like it's
literally right there in front of me
that it's
it's surreal
it's a part of me just as much as it's a
part of them
i think what separates me from
everybody is that
i really do i do all of it
i'm great seeing you at your
consultation and designing and
understanding aesthetics and everything
like that and then
as a chef i'm also the last hand on
every single cake that goes out the door
i have no problem in any medium of art
but for a wedding cake it's always a
celebrate like it's always happy
you can make a sad painting i feel like
can't really make a sad wedding cake we
wouldn't be getting married
i love cake i eat cake every day every
day i eat cake
[Music]
so it's really it's really me
bye